you
I wasn't like all the rest of the kids
people will just pick on me just for
being me
[Music]
this gets weird he stutters kind of each
probably like a [ __ ] or something I'm
just like no I'm pretty good intelligent
[Music]
there are kids who have like a security
blanket have like a security string I
guess
[Music]
if I didn't have this I'm not sure where
I would be probably not in the best
place
[Music]
let's call this on a flower you're just
throwing it out of your hand and the
once it's out there you do whatever you
do with it
[Music]
[Music]
- yo-yo to me is like breathing for
people I can't really function without
it so I was like a dance for me and so I
guess I feel like really complete cuz
it's these three separate things there's
me the music and there's a toy but we're
all together it's like a whole lot of
times it's like some weird form of Tai
Chi maybe it's comforting though Salah
matters even as a kid I just didn't
agree with like phenomenality of things
I didn't fit into any specific molds so
people would just give me my stutter did
did it happen Utley creates barriers
with like trying to kick communicate
this is but this is I don't know it's
like I got tricked my brain into it man
sweet life so interesting man ah this is
a yo-yo I'm gonna do it a little louder
and watch a scooter right as often as
possible I think I found myself in a
fight
10th grade I was on the internet and
there's a team called the bomb squad and
they skateboard and they all throw it
was fascinating me and my friend Sean I
weigh and probably spent like $40 when
we got a bunch of them it was like a
legit turning point like my life like
started to change actually it just
clicked for me
[Music]
I gave up caring about what people
thought it's not about you
[Music]
I feel like it kind of saved me in a way
like all the people that I grew up with
or you know injured or kill Sally it's
weird
[Music]
it distracts you from the negativity
the way that I'll see it is you know I
got a few more kids to throw and out of
trouble you know
like I legitimately felt my own
personality and myself fading into like
the abyss of Baltimore society which is
in void of just negativity I have not
been able to cry at a death since my
brothers years he was 16
I was 11 only Fabio real fancy right
Colin was the first person I
legitimately seen with a yo-yo spinning
in an inning like how do you do this
show me tell me your secrets
maybe it's like getting my first yo-yo
he gave to me he really hit me play with
this and it completely made me forget
about the negativity that was consuming
me on a day-to-day basis so to find not
only friends who won't legitimately get
me killed and I'm having that sense of
family and camaraderie like you know
that's really important for a teenager
you know to just have that have that
connection especially when you know I'm
not getting it for my family
if someone's not comfortable with their
life they should do something to change
it I learn that far down the road but
you know I learned it eventually just
going outside to do something that you
that you truly enjoy you can change
everything state yo-yo
all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
like to go a place can be immediately
pulled in and accepted these people like
I've been waiting to meet you
just like wow I haven't ever had like a
camaraderie like that I really just want
to push it as far as I can
Calvin's like the best throw in
Baltimore there's too many cell phones
tablets
James systems I feel like people as like
a culture bringing lon
it's those things that cut out the real
human interaction that people need in
order to move for that start my own
company and everything yeah yeah this is
my company here's my baby oh yes yeah oh
yeah no string attached man it's like an
extension of my being in a sense so it's
like if I can give it to someone else
and it brings enjoyed it I've done
something today in seven months we've
dropped two brand new yo-yos added like
three players to the roster and truly
developed an entire fan base and so like
oh now there's people with Bowie SEO
tattoos
[Music]
something as small as this can create a
group of people and it might be the one
thing that holds them together but all
of their ideas are in different places
and they could make so much from just
being together a toy is so simple but it
can be so complex
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
Oh
you